knocking and presents for that unity  wise leadership begins now this blade  routine Kawhi Leonard chiseling what a  touch so far three of five nine points  that the stream works in Ankara  shot clock at three co-defendants seven  a left-handed champ I delivered here  heroine chopped clippers with it ten  screen by Harold Liu veteran with his  third think about the degree of  difficulty on this shot going left  but shooting back right awkward worst  has done bringing that championship  experience from from Boston it has  changed a little bit but the Clippers  need to do in the playoffs four quick  points off the bench  [Music]  Williams make his way in the shop okay  got that talk to Danny Green I said  what's it like coming off of a  championship what your office isn't like  you said it's short he did say the  transition was very simple